there's a great Family Guy clip where
there's a transvestite sitting at a bar
and the transvestite is looking at
pornography on his phone and the
bartender comes over and says ma'am you
can't look at pornography at this bar
and the transvestite says no no it's
okay I'm transgender and the bartender
says oh I'm sorry I didn't realize that
okay do whatever you want whenever you
want to do it and that is very much what
seems to occur in our culture whether
we're talking at a bar or in public or
even at schools and one mother has had
enough of it one mother an absolute hero
mom showed up to a school board meeting
wearing frankly a shocking scandalous
completely inappropriate outfit to the
meeting it just so happens that it was
the same outfit that had been worn by a
drag queen at the kids school that very
year and so why is it that a giant
hulking dude can wear a silly leotard
but mother cannot why is it
inappropriate for for a woman to wear
the woman's clothing and not for the
man's School Board didn't seem to have
much of an answer that mother is
Kimberly reichs a stay-at-home mother of
seven children we call that a small
Catholic Family Kimberly thank you for
coming on the show
thank you so much for having me on
Michael I am I'm honored to be on your
show I am so pleased to hear that and I
absolutely adored your stunt what was
the reaction in the room
um Mal's dropped to the floor and there
was one lady in particular sitting
behind me just making snood remarks like
I can't believe she's in that ew put
some clothes on I'm like yeah and that's
when I turned around and addressed her
actually and said yeah if this ticks you
off then it should because this guy came
into our school dressed like this and
that seemed to be okay
so this makes your head spin this pisses
you off in any way shape or form it
should because I'm embarrassed to stand
here in the outfit that I am today but I
have a point to prove and that is that
this outfit should not be ever accepted
in our schools by the way it's it's not
even just what's good for the goose is
good for the gander because you are a
very nice looking lady you still
probably shouldn't wear those things at
school but it makes more sense for a
very nice looking lady to wear ladies
clothing makes a whole lot less sense
for a big hulking dude to wear that
clothing so it's actually much more
inappropriate much more grotesque for
the guy to do it can you explain what
actually happened to prompt your your
appearance at the school board so what
happened was that back in May when I
exposed the drag queen show for what it
was and asked our school board then like
why did this happen how did this get
into our schools what are you planning
on doing to ensure it doesn't happen
again they flat out ignored me they
brushed me under the rug they tried to
censor me and I was not gonna have it
and me along with hundreds of parents
here in Ankeny Iowa we're wanting to
know a hundred and some odd days later
now and 40 days entered the school year
why have we not heard the investigation
results of that GSA program who let him
in why was it allowed and why didn't
that guy not get a background check I
can't go eat lunch with my kids let
alone walk into a school half dressed
and perform for them so what's good for
them is not good for me
you mentioned the GSA which stands for
the gay straight Alliance it's one of
these LGBT clubs in the schools and you
mentioned this drag show and I get that
there are more questions probably than
answers but what actually happened with
the club and the drag queen
so the GSA
um hired this guy to come in to perform
for the children
um as young as 12. he was a 21 year old
male exotic dancer he does not attend
the school he never attended the school
and for him to come in to perform for
our children was just outstanding and
like why what was the purpose of that
and so that's questions that we still
have no answers to how old are the kids
in this club
the youngest one that attended the show
was 12.
it's sick that is absolutely sick I I
assume the club has a faculty advisor is
that right
yes they are supposed to so the GSA is a
school
um credited but not funded
um program it's funded actually by the
CDC and there's teachers that overlook
this GSA program that is supposed to be
monitoring it and so there was two
teachers in particular that are still
teachers there in Ankeny school today
the one is the choir teacher and there's
one that is a um I believe she's an
English teacher and as far as we know
there's no there's been no repercussions
on what they did and why they allowed
this to happen in our schools right now
head on over to ring.com Knowles the
fall is just a magical wonderful time of
the year and it's very very busy the
kids are back at school you got to go
pick them up at the dance recital you
got to go get them from after school you
maybe you're traveling you got the
holidays coming up you got to Jet out to
go get your latest pumpkin spice latte
okay people are really really busy
you're in and out of the house you want
to make sure your home is safe if that's
why you need ring ring yes they've got
the video doorbell you see and speak to
whoever is on your doorstep no matter
where you are in the home at the office
on the other side of the world ring also
has a powerful home security system
that's called ring alarm and then ring
took it up another notch even you're not
just going to protect your doors and
your windows and your physical home
they've got ring alarm Pro GoPro be a
pro just like me CNET calls ring alarm
Pro a giant leap for home security right
now head on over to ring.com these are
the guys that I trust find out how you
can live a little more stress-free this
season with a ring product that is right
for you that is ring.com
Knowles you were about to make me feel
better when you said yes the school has
given accreditation to this club but
they don't give the club any money until
you told me that the club is funded by
the federal government that actually
makes me feel a lot worse but okay I'm
not going to blame a 12 year old for
making a stupid choice and inviting a
drag queen into a club 12 year olds make
stupid decisions all the time that's
pretty much the definition of being a 12
year old but you're telling me there are
two faculty advisors here so then my
question is one did they know what what
did they know and when did they know it
and two if they did not know then what
kind of negligence is that for a club
advisor
oh they knew for sure because they posed
in front of
um on the stage at the end there was a
huge photo at the end of the stage that
showed all the teachers happily standing
there
with all the students that performed in
that drag queen show and who attended so
that without question the teachers need
to be fired I I would imagine really I
have and you and the parent the other
parents have asked for this
yes we have we have demanded it and they
refuse to do it have you been able to
speak to any political leaders right now
I mean I'm pleased that you can come on
my show we'll spread this as far and
wide as we can it's a national program
we have international listeners so I I
think absolutely that people who are
listening right now should call in and
put a lot of public pressure on to get
these teachers fired get this club shut
down and keep the transvestites out of
the 12 year olds classrooms but has
anyone spoken to uh you know your member
of Congress Senators that no one is
speaking up against this who's actually
in elected office
no but I did have five State reps they
call me or text me saying that they were
proud of what I did and they hope that I
come up to the Capitol this session and
start protesting
um to help get them to get a law passed
so this doesn't happen any further how
long do you think this has been going on
at your kid's school
um I'm guessing at least two years since
covet started and that's just being
bringing to light because a lot of this
stuff we saw online and so a lot of the
kids are more open about talking about
it and so I don't think if without covid
we would have seen it as quickly but
since with coven and since we had to go
to like online stuff when the lockdowns
were in price that's when we started
realizing this agenda that they are
pushing on our children
what is so spooky to me is that you're
not in New York you're not in California
you're not in Chicago or Washington DC
you're in Iowa or do you just happen to
be in an extremely radical left-wing
town or County
unfortunately yes I'm in one of the
liberalist towns in Ankeny but that's
okay because last session we actually
got
um the town flipped from Blue to Red we
ended up getting six seats overturned in
our city we had three students three um
school board members overturned one city
mayor and two city councilmen so we do
have more of a conservative
um running now but it's they have a huge
mess to clean up and I think that
they're just getting buried left and
right and I have to imagine no matter
how left-wing the town is I mean
obviously it can't be all that left wing
if if the political Tides have shifted
so much but no matter how left-wing your
neighbors are
I think if you did a public opinion poll
of your neighbors I can't imagine that
most of them are going to support drag
shows for 12 year olds right am I am I
am I giving too much credit to to your
county no there's very small amount of
them that will actually want that in our
County there most people do not want it
but most people it gets hidden from so
like the GSA program was not made public
that this was going to happen it was not
made known to all students it was in it
was basically exclusive for those
students in the GSA and it did happen
after hours but then that just means us
more questions it just makes us ask how
did they get um into the school building
after hours who let them in who who
approved all this because there's
protocols that you have to go through in
order to be able to host any kind of
show in the in the school and the
administration of this of the particular
school has to sign off you have to have
the approval of the super intended and
none of that happened here and it all
just got brushed onto the rug like why
why is that okay
you know I I I I sometimes see this
issue approach from the perspective of
you know well what's the big deal what's
the big deal why do you guys care so
much about this and I think well you can
obviously flip that on the other side
and and say well you know we're not the
ones changing the way that we view sex
and education and kids you guys are the
ones changing it you're spending so much
time and energy and money doing that
you're obviously very focused on it's
another question why can a child not see
a drag show why a child must see a drag
show but then the question I have is
what about this drag queen himself what
is it about this guy that that makes him
so determined to prance around half
naked for little kids
right and that's our questions too as
concerned parents like what makes an
adult want to perform and get the
approval of children like why would you
want to do that if you don't have an
alternative motive I don't know what to
tell parents when parents write into me
all the time and they say you know I
don't know what to do with my kid my
school's gone really woke and obviously
now you've got sexual performances for
12 year olds by guys who are obviously
little on the perverted side if they're
prancing around in women's clothing so
this is a genuinely a dangerous
situation you've got seven kids
do you feel comfortable sending them to
this public school
I don't and that's why I pulled them for
this year so they you did I just
hechman and so he's pretty he's like Mom
I know what's going on I'm okay I just
want to go and so I did pull my younger
two that are in school out I have two of
them I have two kids that are out of
school and I have three kids in school
and so they are out of the school system
but it creates a problem I mean you you
know you've taken the charge to be
fruitful and multiply very very well and
you know you're doing your your part to
uh to uh you know out flank the left not
only by persuasion but also by
outbreeding them which I I understand to
be much more fun so good on you for
doing that but it creates a sort of a
financial problem too it's it's not as
though most people in this country can
afford to send seven kids to private
school it's not as though a lot of
mothers can even afford to stay home and
homeschool all day long I mean these are
this is very very expensive and so for a
lot of people there's not a whole lot of
choice here it's just either send your
kid to the school with the [ __ ] or
don't send your kid to school at all
right and that's exactly the tough part
we are in we are in that tough situation
right now just with like trying to make
Financial ends meet because of the fact
that you know I can't work anytime
outside the home during the during the
school hours because I'm home with the
kids watching them now and it does make
it a little difficult but God will
provide and we will make sure that we
can keep going and I will make sure that
my kids are not indoctrinated yeah and
best I can to Shield them from what's
happening in our schools have any
teachers spoken out against this you
know obviously there's the two faculty
advisors to the club who are bringing
these this weirdo in and taking weird
pics with the kids but surely there have
got to be some good teachers here who
are joining you at the school board
meeting and speaking out against it
no I'm a lonely person standing up there
and anytime they see my name on the
agenda the board will actually stack the
stack it against me so when I first
brought this to the attention I'm good
at making posters I like to make posters
and held them up because that's my thing
and so the very first time I addressed
them after the GSA program happened they
actually cut Life feed they had
technical difficulties
and so but as soon as the first person
that they brought in was on it it worked
and so there's three of us that spoke up
against it and there was about 20 of
them that they brought in to spoke to
speak for the GSA and how they needed to
have it in school how does this work
with the federal funding because you
know I was a member of a ton of clubs in
school I ran a bunch of clubs you know I
was very involved in the
extracurriculars and I don't remember
the federal government giving me money
for my for the choir club or the band or
the plays or the student government or
any of that so what is it about the the
gay club that gets federal dollars I'm
guessing it's a mental illness and
that's what why the cbc's got it and I
mean what I don't know what other way
why they would have it besides it's a
mental illness and that's why the CDC is
funding it right well yes if you're a
man who thinks that he's a woman I guess
by definition that's a mental illness
and so but but you know usually you
would hope that the C CDC or the the
more medically inclined agencies of our
government would be spending their money
trying to cure mental problems not uh
toward exacerbating them yes I agree
right now text Knowles to 98 98 98 the
labor Department's Consumer Price Index
which catalogs the cost of goods
Services food and rent Rose 0.4 percent
over the month of August double what
many economists had anticipated perhaps
worse core inflation which excludes food
and gas prices so the highest increase
last month that it's seen since August
of 1982 what is the current
Administration doing to quell that surge
of inflation
spending more taxpayer dollars of course
don't bury your head in the sand while
your savings deplete diversify into gold
with Birch gold today text Knowles
Canada wlas to 98 98 98 and Birch gold
will send you a free info kit on
protecting your savings with gold in a
tax sheltered account the experts over
at Birch gold have almost 20 years of
experience in converting IRAs and 401ks
into precious metals IRAs with an A plus
rating from the Better Business Bureau
countless five star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers why
have you not checked them out yet gold
has always been your best hedge against
inflation head on over right now to
Birch gold you text Knowles kwles to 98
98 98 and Birch gold will send you a
free info kit on diversifying into gold
tax-free take the necessary steps to
hedge against inflation today protect
your hard-earned money get your free
info kit by texting Knowles kwles to
989-898
now what about the parents in the
community I mean or because I I bet you
I I told you I bet you if you did a poll
right now at 90 plus of the parents
would be on your side in terms of do you
think these drag queens should dance
around for kids uh how many are actually
standing up with you at the meetings
none none even of the parents
no there was about two of them when we
started when I first brought it to the
school board meeting and there's maybe
five of us that will stand up at all
like all the time but when I went up
against them just this last Monday it
was just me and another mom why do you
think that is
um I think it's because of the backlash
that people get here in in our town and
I don't think people like that
negativity they don't like to be put
themselves out there so especially if
you own a small business if you own a
small business in this town and you're
speaking up against what they want you
to they'll find a way to shut you down
of course of course and you even think
with some parents I bet they don't want
their kids grades to be affected you
know everyone wants to get into a
college and you know just kind of check
that box and so
I I see this everywhere when people come
up they'll ask me at speech is Michael
should I speak out or should I keep my
head down and get the good grade and
move on and there's so many incentives
just to keeping your mouth shut I guess
I'm just so uh
uh surprised really that this is going
on not just in the big cities but even
in small towns and states that are
supposed to be pretty normal
yeah yeah and I mean the city definitely
comes after me I mean they are
at my doorstep at all times the ancient
police are after me and I mean it's just
whatever you know I have thick skin and
they can throw whatever daggers they
want at me and I'll take them because if
it helps save our kids that's what I'm
here for and I will never stop working
for our kids what do your kids think
about it
they love it actually
um they're like my mom's just a hero and
it was funny because like when my little
Olivia when we got the mass law passed
in our state
um she was a huge part of that and I
remember her going up to her principal
after we got the law passed that they
can't mandate mask on she walked up the
principal she was like Miss Ryan Miss
Ryan guess what and she's like what
Olivia and she's like my mom made a rule
and you can't put a mask on me and she
flipped her hair and she walked into
that school I was so proud of her
because she felt so empowered and it was
just like yep that's my kid wow that is
fabulous oh my gosh I love it so oh I
wish we had more time even to touch on
that but you also helped spearhead the
effort to get rid of the stupid mask
rules yes I was the mom that was talking
about my daughter had the staph
infection and it caused um staph
infection on her face four times so we
got a medical exemption to not have a
mask in school and that's when they
segregated her they literally put her on
one side of the room compared to
everybody else on the other and so I am
suing the Ankeny school district for the
retaliation they're doing with my child
they a judge did come in and dismiss my
case saying there wasn't enough evidence
so we are appealing it and we are moving
forward with the case wow oh I I just
absolutely love it you just think of the
irony here the same people who are
saying that it's it's of the utmost
importance that poor little kids cover
up their face entirely with the mask or
the same ones saying that you don't need
to cover up your legs or your midriff or
anything else if you're a crazy guy
dancing around for the GSA Club yep
absolutely insane well I Kimberly I wish
you all the best of luck where where
does the effort stand now I mean is it
just at an impasse and you're waiting
for a response from the school board or
how can people as I suspect they're
going to want to do how can people help
you
um they can go to our website at
iowamamabears.com and that's
iowamamabears.com and they can help by
supporting or donating whatever you feel
God leading you to do to help out we are
appreciative of everything uh that
that's really wonderful and since you're
willing to give some advice and you know
help lead this kind of movement I would
be remiss if I didn't ask given all your
political activity when are we going to
see you run for office
I hope soon because honestly I think
that's where God's leading me and I mean
maybe in 2024 when I get everything off
my all the spears off my back for now
but I think my fight right now is to
focus on the schools and so this next
year I think that's my biggest thing is
I have to be boots on the ground in your
face
um to these people because yes I can get
a lot done being running but I can also
get a lot more done without having my
hands tied just being a mom right right
you you clearly are getting stuff
accomplished right now would be
absolutely fabulous
if you could run I think it's a really
really important issue and I think I
think the left is Running Scared here I
think it's totally a house of cards you
saw what happened in Virginia in
particular this transgender issue in the
schools people across voting
demographics realize that it is
completely insane and I know that the
squishes even the squishy conservatives
even the squishy normal people They they
want to back away from it they say it's
a culture War issue oh no I don't want
to be called a phobe or a bigot or
whatever keep your head down normal
people realize that this is insane no
sane person with two brain cells to rub
together in a moral conscience thinks
that a pervert in address should be
dancing around for 12 year olds at the
GSA Club okay so this is a completely
winning issue I think you were doing a
great job leading the way on it and I I
think you're doing it in a way that's
very very funny but it's calling
attention to a very very serious issue
Kimberly reichs I look forward to seeing
the launch of your campaign and I look
forward to seeing more accomplishments
in the meantime
thank you so much
[Music]
[Music]